a frigid landscape of snow and ice the
natural habitat for a polar specialist
but this is kiev's war scarred outer
suburbs not the Antarctic Wilderness
Elena and her colleagues should have
been exploring this year
Ukraine's National Antarctic scientific
center expedition was due to set off
last February till Russia's Invasion
froze their dreams
instead they've hung up the polar wear
and their lives have taken very
different paths some of our polar
scientists are operating in different
kind of France so some of their mind and
bars some of them in the South but one
group of the scientists form their own
unit and they called themselves military
Penguins I believe it's a
characteristically Ukrainian flourish of
humor to help see them through these
dark times they even have their own
badge you can see there is penguin in
Kozak style he's angry by the way this
penguin Battalion of Arctic scientists
is doing real fighting in some of the
war's toughest battles this guy is also
on the on the somewhere near Bahamut
again this is for sure
yeah
Elena can see what the war is doing to
friends and colleagues she's known
intimately for years I see how he
becomes older and older and also he
becomes sentiment when very sentimental
about small things he like he could
start crying watching some some small
things or saying and and what is also
important that we start to say I love
you I care about you much more than
before
we actually love marchenko is the
Antarctic Center's technical director
just out of a key of Hospital following
a close call in bakmut the fighting he
describes there
is a hellish cacophony of pounding
artillery and hand-to-hand combat
we had a very difficult night battle if
I ever were stormed by 24 of them they
broke in from part of the building we
did not control and the fighting was at
five or six meters grenades flying
everyone shooting grenades fell just one
and a half meter from my head as I was
in a pit under the
stairslav can't afford to think of what
he'd be doing if Russia hadn't attacked
I'm completely focused on the war but I
really wanted to end to return to a
peaceful life again I want to create
something not destroy it but for now I
have to destroy unfortunately
Elena is busy helping too she's raising
money and supplies food helmets drones
to send to the front lines things that
might end up saving the lives of her
colleagues the story of Ukraine's
Antarctic scientists and how they became
the penguin Legion of Frontline Warriors
and crowdfunders is one of millions of
similar transformations
everyday lives indefinitely put on hold
so they can help their country in its
hour of need Rory challenge Al Jazeera
Kiev